the United States has always had a
pretty sacred rule and that is we don't
leave our men or women in uniform behind
and that dates back to the earliest days
of our revolution we have consulted with
Congress for quite some time about the
possibility that we might need to
execute a prisoner exchange in order to
recover sergeant Bergdahl we saw an
opportunity we were concerned about
sergeant Bergdahl's help
we had the cooperation of the Qataris to
execute an exchange and we seized that
opportunity and the process was
truncated because we want to make sure
that we did not miss that window with
respect to the circumstances of Sergeant
Bergdahl's captured by the Taliban
we obviously have not been interrogating
sergeant Bergdahl he is recovering from
five years of captivity with the Taliban
he's having to undergo a whole battery
of tests and he is going to have to
undergo a significant transition back
into life he has not even met with his
family yet which indicates I think the
degree to which we take this transition
process seriously something that we
learned from the Vietnam era but let me
just make a very simple point here and
that is regardless of the circumstances
whatever those circumstances may turn
out to be we still get an American
soldier back if he's held in captivity
period full stop we don't condition that
and that's what every mom and dad who
sees a a son or daughter sent over into
war theaters should expect from not just
their commander-in-chief but the United
States of America in terms of potential
threats the release of the the Taliban
will being held in Guantanamo was
conditioned on the Qataris keeping eyes
on them and creating a structure in
which we can monitor their activities we
will be keeping eyes on them is there
the possibility of some of them trying
to return to activities that are
detrimental to us absolutely that's been
true of all the prisoners that were
released from Guantanamo there's a
certain recidivism rate that takes place
I wouldn't be doing it if I thought that
it was contrary to American national
security and we have confidence that we
will be in a position to go after them
if in fact they are engaging activities
that threaten our defenses but this is
what happens at the end of wars that was
true for George Washington that was true
for Abraham Lincoln that was true for
FDR that's been true every combat
situation that at some point you make
sure that you try to get your folks back
and that's the right thing to do